Mark: I'm just having an existential crisis. I just...
*Bob snort-chuckles*
Bob: You seem to have those a lot
Mark: I'm just- I'm not even gonna show the game cause I'm just running in circles, making people PUKE
*Bob starts laughing*
Mark: I... *slight chuckle* Listen
Bob: Why are you running in circles? That's the part I don't fully get.
Mark: Because!!-
Mark: This is what I used to do in World of Warcraft when I had nothing to do-
Mark: I was waiting for a raid or I was waiting for people to log on, I wouldn't go out
Mark: I wouldn't farm! I wouldn't do anything. I'd just run in circles
Bob: You just run endlessly in circles?
Mark: YES!!!
Mark: That's what I do-!
Mark: It's just like I- I don't have anything to do and I don't know where to go so... I just it's like it's an analogy for my life
Mark: I just end up running around doing nothing and panicking about all the things that I DO!
Mark: And complaining about the problems that are happening in my LIFE!!
Bob: You could vomit it out. (Bob being Bob) That'd probably work.
Mark: I can't vomit! I haven't- I haven't even eaten anything.
Mark: I've aten something... I- I ate
Mark: I "@"
Mark: I did eat something BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT
Bob: you had "@"
Mark: Yeah, it's not a congealed evil that I holed up inside of me and I vomit out in a black orb of nothingness
Mark: It's just- I just- I can't do it (proper English)
Mark: I just have- I have these
Mark: Crisis moments where I was just like when problems surmount too high and I just can't physically deal with them
Mark: I can't capable- *Mark noises* I am incapable of handling them. So circles is all I DO
*Mark huffs*
Bob: It's okay buddy
Mark: I dunno if it is man. I dunno if it is.
Mark: This has been a WHIRLWIND of a stream.
*Bob laughs*
Bob: Just you, just there like-
Bob: "I don't know if it is- I DUNNO"
Bob: Oh my God, I see the space elevator in the distance. Wtf? (Bob continuing to be Bob)
*Bob laughs*
Mark: Yeah, holy shit
Mark: Gawd...
Mark: I wish my people could see this
Mark: But it's just- I can't SHOW 'EM
Mark: Cuz my RENDERING is so shit
Bob: Oh my gawd it's so big
Mark: It's so BIG
Bob: It's soo biig
Mark: It's so *BIG*
Mark: and other people can't *SEE* it because I-
Mark: OH MY GOD
Mark: My MONITOR'S covering up my webcam!!
Mark: *Exasperated groan/scream*
Mark: aaaah!...
*Wade and Bob laughing in background*
*Still laughing*
Mark: God I just- I just
*laughing*
Mark: My big fancy 144p
*Dying of laughter*
*laughing*
Mark: 1440p Hertz MONITOR
Mark: is just
*still laughing*
Mark: UGGHH
*laughter*
Mark: I just-
Bob: You got one of those...
Bob: You got one of those 1440P Hertz monitors?
Mark: *chuckles* I ju- just- You know- You know how it is
Mark: You have one of those days, I'm still fifth in line
Mark: I- I'm not going anywhere
Mark: I'm not going anywhere in- in LIFE with THIS
Mark: I don't know man.
Bob: The space elevator is touching things
Mark: That would be so cool to show but I CAN'T!!
*Bob laughing*
Mark: OH IT'S SO PRETTY! YES IT IS!!!
Mark: I have so much potential in my life and yet I-I
Mark: I squander it by never going the- the full distance
Mark: The extra mile
Mark: I just don't do it. I can't do it
Mark: So I have no- I have no hope
Mark: Oh please, just tell me it's gonna be okay.
Bob: Mark, it's gonna be fine bud, you know...
Mark: I DON'T BELIEVE YOU AT ALL!!!
Mark: I don't believe you at all!!
Bob: You need to- you need to just-
Bob: Build some- build some- build somethin'.
Mark: WHAT??!
Bob: Just-
Mark: I can't- I don't- I don't even know what or how
Bob: Just build somethin' bud.
Mark: I have supplies but no willpower... I can't do it!
Bob: Just click, just get some stuff, and just click some stuff. It's okay-
I DUNNO MAN!!
Bob: It's okay
eugh
Bob: Just chat- If you want a little insight.. Everyday on the- on the tour we did was basically like this
Bob: The rest of us would be sitting in the backstage, hanging out, and Mark would just be STORMING around, having VIOLENT crisis of faith in himself
Bob: The rest of us would be sitting in the backstage, hanging out, and Mark would just be STORMING around, having violent crisis of faith in himself
Mark: *chuckles* I just couldn't-
Bob: It's okay, it's okay.. It comes and goes
Mark: OH GOD, but it's really coming and there's no one to go with
Mark: I don't know- alright I guess
*Mark sniffs*
Mark: Maybe it's not so bad after all
*Bob laughing*
Mark: I dunno...
Bob: So he comes- he comes right down outta it, chat
Mark: cuz maybe I'll just look at some memes.. huh.. that usually helps people, right? (Uhh yeah... sure...?)
Bob: You could do meme- meme review live!
Mark: I'll do meme review live...
Bob: Go- go look at eye bleach or something.
Mark: Oh
Mark: But you know what??
Mark: my computer will lag up even opening a CHROME BROWSER
Mark: Cuz there's only 32 GIGS OF RAM IN THIS!
Mark: Ah I can't do it- I can't do it. There's no point
Mark: Memes can't help this.
Mark: It's the one thing memes can't fix- it's
ME (Same)
(Bob wheezes)
Mark: I'm broken.. Everything about me is broken.
*Gasp*
Mark: I'm about to turn 30 years old (fossil)
*Bob laughs*
Mark: Exactly TODAY! Exactly TODAY is 3 months away! 3 months away and I'll be 30 years old (FOSSIL!!!)
*Gasp*
Mark: Now what happened? I squandered my life playing video games
Mark: What have I done??
(Bob wheezes)
Mark: I'M DOING IT RIGHT NOW!!
Mark: BUT I'M NOT EVEN PLAYING!!
Mark: *Another gasp* I'M RUNNING IN A CIRCLE!!!
I  H A V E N ' T  B U I L T  A  D A M N  T H I N G !!!
Mark: I'm in the woods-! (yay the game is back on!)
Mark: I'm in the forest-!
Mark: I'm zapping a TREE!!!
Mark: That's what I've been doing
Mark: I've been tasing trees!
Bob: You doing okay??
Bob: You uh- you feeling any better?
Mark: yeah..yeah
Bob: Get it out?
Mark: I'm fine. I'm good(3x).. it's okay.
Bob: Oh, yeah?
Mark: it's all good. It's good. It's good. All right, I'm good
Mark: Sorry, yes, I'm good. I'm fine now
Bob: It just- it comes and goes you just gotta wait for it to go.
Mark: It's- it's gone. It's gone, I'm good(x3).